good morning Kurt how are you I'm good
how are you I'm great how do you expect
tonight's game to play out uh I expect
it to be a low scoring affair I expect
the Patriots to keep it close I expect
the Texans to win solely based on the
fact that I don't know anything about
Jacoby Brissett at this level so you go
with the more veteran quarterback and
Brock has played I think solid they
haven't been great in the red zone but I
think they'll score enough and you know
I but I do think the Patriots might have
a chance to win it in the end if Jacoby
can make a few plays for them we'll see
but that's kind of what I expect what
kind of game plan do you expect from
Belichick to have a rookie quarterback
going against this defense no I think
it's going to be simple josh mcdaniels
is one of the best in the league in my
opinion at creating easy opportunities
for quarterbacks he'll come out in the
first 15 no scripted plays and he will
throw probably 15 different formations
different movements especially if you
have Gronk invented in there move them
outside and he will try to create easy
opportunities for Jacoby early in the
game so I think he'll do a great job of
mixing it up and they'll get some easy
throws they'll be able to you know to
move the ball and do some of those
things you know it's those critical
situations the third down situation the
red zone situations where you're really
tested as a quarterback to see what
you're seeing what your knowing to make
some of those tight throws and that'll
probably be the difference in the game
it's Jacoby can make those plays I think
New England has a chance to win this
game if he struggles there you can only
do so much designing things as a coach
but I think Josh McDaniels will have a
great plan and we'll make some give him
some easy opportunities very much like
he did for Jimmy Garoppolo against
Arizona simple game plan got some easy
throws and I think got him into a rhythm
and able to win that game what do you
remember about your first NFL story um
yeah I remember a lot i remember you
know the nervousness beforehand running
out of the tunnel i remember a you know
the name of the play 270
on f / that I threw my first touchdown
pass on and remember getting picked off
by Ray Lewis my first interception on a
little Jew crowd I remember beating Rod
Woodson on a slanting go with torry holt
to the side for my third touchdown of
the game I remember a lot about that
good you threw three touchdowns had two
interceptions threw for 300 yards made
it look cunning easy didn't you well I
don't know about that I had a lot of
help but it was definitely fun other
than trying to chase Ray Lewis down a
tackler but once I look I do not do what
was what were you nervous about yeah i
think the just nervous about you know
you're being on that stage for the first
time and i didn't have any questions on
whether i could play but the nervousness
is you don't want your first game to be
a bad one you know you're going to have
some bad games but that first came out
after waiting as long as i did to get
there you just wanted that first one to
be good you know you just wanted to show
people I belong here now the second one
might not have been as good that's ok
but the first one there was you were
just so nervous because you wanted
things to go right especially early in
the game so now everybody on the
sideline took a deep breath all the fans
were like okay maybe this guy can play a
little bit and so that's where the
nervousness came in it wasn't so much I
don't know if I can play at this level
it was I want things to go right early
in the game I'm looking at the first
month of your career 1990-91 for know
you through 14 touchdowns and three
interceptions that's pretty good Kurt
that's how I wanted to do it I was kind
of I I played it out in my mind it
happened to just work out that way you
know the great thing about that
situation for me was that the way Mike
Martz saw the game and called the game
in the way our office was designed was
very much in line with how I played the
game so I was very fortunate that I
didn't get caught in my first situation
in an offense that didn't fit me and I
had to struggle through it the throws
that we made the things he asked me to
do were all things that were my
strengths and so it was kind of like a
perfect storm not only did I have
tremendous players around me but I was
in a system that really fit my skill set
and because of that I
you know I believe that's why we were
able to have success and I was able to
have success so early you know in that
season he's Kurt Warner NFL Network
joining a Stan Patrick show how do you
explain Jared golf and maybe the lack of
progress there uh I mean you know it's
always different for different guys I
think you know the hardest thing is that
when I look at that situation I don't
know who's there to help him you know of
course Todd Gurley is there to help you
but when it comes to passing the
football and you're a rookie quarterback
you need guys that can win on the
outside you need guys that can create
opportunities for you on the outside
then I wonder sometimes with these young
guys I mean we're looking at Carson
Wentz and his success that he's having
well he's played against two teams where
his guys on the outside were better they
were forcing him to throw against man
coverage his guys were winning he was
making the throws that's the way to have
success as a young guy you'd like to
think that that was set up that way and
st. in LA with girly that they're going
to stack the box would give you one on
one on the outside but I'm just looking
at it going okay if you get that who's
winning for you on the outside so I just
wonder if the lack of playmakers around
him doesn't allow him to get the
confidence and have the success early
and maybe doesn't allow him to show
himself and the coaches to gain
confidence in him as well and maybe a
reason why he's a little bit behind the
eight ball um you know but but there's
always a learning curve you know what's
the aww sounds like you know where did
you come from you know how quickly can
you grasp the ability to see and react
to things and that's what I'm hearing
about Carson Wentz that's so impressive
is that even though everything's simple
for them he's seeing and reacting very
quickly his intelligence and his ability
to react within that intelligence is
very very good and so even if it's
simple he's able to get the right guy
find the right guy and make the throw on
time where a lot of young guys struggle
with that did you ever have a situation
like you have now where Josh Norman
which down one side of the field or
Richard Sherman stay on one side of the
field and you know so they're best
corner was not even you could line up
opposite your best
to their best corner um I mean I can't
remember specifics but yeah there were
times that I think you know back in the
day if you didn't have a deion sanders
you know not a lot of guys necessarily
you know traveled because they weren't
necessarily good enough to go we could
just he's going to shut down your best
receiver so there was a lot of times we
would play against teams where we knew
who their right corner was who their
left corner was we knew what the
strengths of each of them were even if
it was their best corner we knew how we
could attack them and so we could always
create accordingly and go okay this
guy's weakness on the left side is this
will call that route over there this
guy's weakness is this because you just
didn't see that many quote unquote shut
down corners or whatever you want to
call them where they would just travel
and go well I can take away your best
guy and then I think on top of that you
look at some of the guys i played with
you know i mean you don't have a guy
that can stop tory hold and I see Bruce
you don't have a guy that can stop
Anquan Boldin and Larry Fitzgerald so
even if you want to go there I would
create opportunities for that other guy
who was also a number one receiver and
very seldom did you have two guys extra
cover you know cover both ok good to
visit with you Curt have fun this
weekend thanks for joining us sounds
good kardia that's Kurt Warner NFL
network analyst super bowl MVP NFL MVP
with the ramps the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience